Hey, listen to this. This is just a pleasure
to read. Rudy Giuliani is being sued by
Dominion voting systems over false election
claims. The lawsuit against Rudy Giuliani
is because he is accused of carrying out
a, quote, viral disinformation campaign.
Dominion Voting Systems has filed a defamation
lawsuit. The lawsuit was filed this morning
and it's 107 pages long. It accuses not only
Giuliani, as I mentioned, of carrying out a viral
disinformation campaign about dominion. It accuses
him of putting out their demonstrably false
allegations to enrich himself through legal
fees and his podcast. And that's true. A big
theme on his popular podcast for Rudy Giuliani was
making false claims about Dominion voting systems.
The suit is suing Rudy for one
point three billion dollars. Yeah,
they're not going to get that. I know.
And it makes these it files this suit
on the basis of 50 different statements that
Rudy made at legislative hearings via tweets
as well as on his podcast and while being
interviewed on conservative news media.
Now, as you know, Rudy Giuliani was supposedly
getting 20 grand a day to defend Donald Trump
or represent Donald Trump in the election fraud,
bogus cases. We later learned that Donald Trump
directed his team not to pay Rudy Giuliani. And
we don't know if or how much of that 20 grand a
day Rudy has actually been able to collect. But
look at this. Does anybody feel sorry for Rudy?
You throw your reputation away to peddle
baseless conspiracy theories for Trump,
which, of course, go nowhere. Trump ends up saying
don't pay him. And now Rudy is going to accumulate
significant legal fees because he's getting
sued for the things that he said. Now,
he should be sued, he should be disbarred. And
in the end, he should be held accountable for
his role in the insurrection, which now I don't
just mean on the day of the insurrection saying
let's do trial by combat. That's bad enough.
But I mean the two and a half to two months
that he spent ginning up anger over non-existent
voter fraud claims with his hearings and his
flatulence at the hearings and everything
else. And you can actually make the case
that Dominion Voting Systems has really been
irreparably damaged by the false allegations.
It is hard to think of a time where I would take
the side of a corporation against an individual.
But the Dominion voting systems name any election
that Dominion Voting Systems is involved in.
You were going to have people who come out of
the woodwork and claim fraud because of Dominion
voting systems. These people, Rudy Giuliani and
Sidney Powell and and Lin Wood and whoever, they
really have destroyed the reputation of Dominion
voting systems for no reason whatsoever. So
we'll see what happens in these
lawsuits. In terms of Rudy, listen,
a lot of people continue to say Rudy was just
compromised. That's why Rudy did all of these
things. He was compromised. We don't yet know
the full extent of the details, but he was.
If Borat can get Rudy into the
position Rudy found himself in,
there's no doubt that professionals would be able
to manipulate Rudy Giuliani. There's no question
about that. And. When you think about it, a lot
of the actions from some of these Republicans
can be explained by them being compromised.
I'm not saying they are, but for example,
Lauren Bobert owed or owes money to the IRS.
That would often prevent people from getting
a security clearance. But politicians are
still able to run and get elected regardless.
And it puts her in a position of being very easy
to have over a barrel if the right people get
involved. Rudy again. Rudy, throwing away
his reputation, had strong favorability as
the mayor of New York City after 9/11, and that
went away over the following years and then just
completely imploding in terms of his reputation
during the presidency of Donald Trump.
Now, by the way, this should be exciting
news for anybody who still believes there was
evidence of election fraud, this lawsuit. What
do I mean by that if the lawsuit goes forward?
The evidence that Rudy Giuliani and his cronies
supposedly have about the minyon voting systems
would come out in the discovery phase of the
lawsuit. So for those of you and I know that
there are some of you still in my audience who
think any day now the evidence will come out, this
lawsuit against Rudy is the perfect opportunity to
get all of that evidence of voter fraud out during
the discovery phase. I'll be waiting. I look
forward to seeing if we ever see that information.